that's colton brewer yeah brewer making
his fourth start last time out against
toronto gave up three home runs couldn't
get out of the fourth inning hopefully
he can do better tonight dansby 303
average five homers 20 runs batted in
and a line drive into center jackie
bradley jr won't get there and danged me
now with a hit in 14 out of his last 15
games marcake is the batter with two
outs
he is lying down the left field line
near the monster that is a fair ball it
ricochets off the wall peraza a little
trouble dansby's flying around third
he's streaking for the play he's gonna
belly flop in safely and nick marquez
does it again with another double
unbelievable max freed who's the braves
number one and the last four starts 3-0
with a .81 pitching some of his best
baseball that we've seen verdugo 291
five home runs for alex and a 1-1
he cracks that the other way that's into
the corner
so he's gonna have an extra base hit
right into that door
and alex is into second base give him a
four game hitting streak and sends up
rafael devers 240 with six home runs
base hit that one into right center
field roduko rounding you will score
easily and this game is quickly tied 1-1
as devers comes up with his 20th rbi on
a solid base hit red sox coming up here
in the bottom of the third inning at
fenway in a 1-1 tie with atlanta and a
lefties 1-2 to verdugo
he sucks that one the other way headed
toward the wall it's going to be off the
wall and it just dies there on the track
and it's another double for verdugo
who is two for two
vasquez oh for one he's grounded a third
and a tapper dugo is gonna move up throw
on to first base in time alex into third
i thought that was really aggressive
very aggressive and great baseball a
great read of what the third baseman had
to do on that beau guards is over one
struck out two down as the infield backs
up
shook off a couple fastballs
is that a block
yes oh yes yes it's a block they're
going to bring in a run
here comes verdugo in the score
red sox lead to 2-1 on the block
let's see what he does here does he step
off first i think he made a movement
first great move
and then he stepped up that's a good
call that's what happens when you're
shaking off too many signs
all right braves are down to run adam
duvall leads off base is empty for adam
and a high towering fly ball that's
headed for the monster and the light
tower it is long gone out into the mass
pike
adam duvall has tied the game with a
solo home run
and the braves
and boston are even at two in the fourth
marquis the batter second and third
nobody out in a tie game he sprayed a
fastball low and the bases are loaded
with nobody out here comes reniki time
for a change valdez coming on and he
inherits a hornet's nest so let's see
what austin riley has in store for us
line drive to right field that ball's
near the pesky pole that ball is off the
wall he just missed ferdugo plays it
cleanly two runs score streaking around
his mark cakes there'll be no throw to
the plate
and atlanta breaks it open with a triple
off the right field wall by austin riley
who missed a grand slam by about six
inches bringing up duvall and a 3-2
again to duvall
he struck him out with it to camargo
got him yeah well you predicted that
right 93 miles an hour looked like it
was 110 trying to put away tyler flowers
and he does swinging to miss he struck
out three in a row after the triple top
of the sixth inning 5-2 atlanta first
and second with one out nick marcakis is
one for two with a walk
hard hit ball off the glove of arrowroos
swanson rounds third he's coming home
and he's going to score and around to
third goes freeman that was a hard shot
by
nick marcakus that
arrows could not handle went off his
glove and bounced into shallow center
it's now six to two so two on with one
away for xander bogarts
round balling a base hit through the
right side
vasquez rounding third
and he is going to score standing up
down to third safely devers
so bogarts break it out there that makes
it a 6-3 game mark malinson is gonna
come on and try to retire the seven
eight nine hitters he's six out of seven
in saves
frames are not away from sending max
free to six and oh
fly ball to center ender camps out and
the braves are back in the win column
they beat the red sox 6-3 your final
score
it is indeed a 6-0 start for max free
melanson nails down his seventh save
braves have their 20th win
and the big blow austin riley's bases
clearing triple broke open a tie game